what's up guys I'm Ryan right hey I'm
Selena - so today um chelina was telling
me about this rapper that she likes and
you guys might not know this but I
actually do rap I know you're gonna
think it's a joke but it's not legit I'm
legit should I perform at Selena's color
my energy event
it's like rap poetry and you want more
information literally cry like I
actually did make you so mad I know I'm
not kidding like I know stood the event
oh I got some touching [ __ ] right yeah
that's my it's exactly what I said and I
didn't say no she was just like can I
just say yeah I felt things there's
something she didn't say that she was
waiting for the weight no not milk don't
go so she was signing up this person
named little Dickey she said I have to
check out his video
the ex-boyfriend song he's a rapper it
was the first thing I saw from him and I
thought it was so funny so chelina has
seen it already but she really wanted to
show it to me
I laugh every time and let's face it it
has like 10 million views so I said I'm
gonna react to it instead when people
click a little dickie ex-boyfriend video
I might come up in the recommended
section wow we're reacting to it and I
love to be a reaction I love I love to
see the reaction of somebody reacting to
something for that first time see it's
not much you know that's true actually I
find so much joy gratification when
someone wife's when you show them right
enough of the 3-minute intro that was
are so good I was going on Missy boy low
Becky aka mister
love good slogan penis right another
story on man
navigating this gun and Katie she hot as
hell anybody crazy with China shaving
and it don't spell it out for chickens
like this wanna let a different buddies
take them plus she really gonna make him
ready ticket got me thinking she the one
man you can put the cloud shot
everything on man get a lot of those
come close up where's the most that I
felt so damn explore yet if I'm all day
and I'm gonna shake it I hit it I wish I
was kidding
never gonna feel shy before because
she's only [ __ ] one guy before no I
really wanna break this or she my
sweetie 3.14 on sanitation and
masturbation and now my artist auto
racing guys she said tonight was even
maybe do some fun is killed hey I'm down
I gotta go all out I'm gonna pound man
crazy like an elaborate black man a
shake but on the way to the bread we
passes can you seem to know baby is
horse is and she say dick it is is my
ex-boyfriend John usually
this is crazy I can't believe this guy
used to fly Katie Katie squeeze in a
shady like things and above in the
queasy this ain't okay and I may say
let's get him some I say okay even
though I got it later
in the back so I was oh my god look at
that Hey because the [ __ ] is flying
today
don't know what to do thick is really
huge I didn't realize the penis could be
so smooth I know she's missing that my
penis is embed or looking closer I think
that is Nick has now what the [ __ ] is
that it's like a punching bag
hey the head is amazing of my day
looking like a raisin Kim told you same
anytime I slit dominators crazy it was a
[ __ ] I killed you got a Rouge Grist
dick your mom's a drive-through - okay
my guys cuz I simply can't survive that
the seal I was in between us the house
so I got it
I don't know about a stick now let's go
home and get your leg and then that took
us to my crib and you know that we
barely slept and I gave really no like I
was selling kraggen when I came I pull
that and that it all over her left eye
oh I love it I love yes his stories are
amazing though
really it it's weird it's like the kind
of rap I like I know it's comedy but I
mean it's like honest
yeah it's I've heard a lot of like
comedy rapping one there's some that I
like some of the Lonely Island but they
act like what flight of the conchords
does sometimes with something but a lot
of time I'm like yeah that was funny
because it's like a real thing that
people go through right especially I've
been in areas like yeah but yeah
oh yeah till I mean like bumping into an
ex-boyfriend or see what it's like it
always like oh yeah like no matter what
but like especially with their good look
at your leg off and you like you learned
unfortunate facts that you don't want to
know but you had to know you're like wow
I'm really amazing yeah and his rap was
really good like if yeah you flow really
well I think he's very talented I think
that he's definitely up-and-coming like
he's doing a great thing all his music
videos are so like there they all tell a
story and they're all just like I think
that he's definitely like the funniest
person like like I said like I've
listened like Lonely Island and like
other rappers that are funny but I think
like his whole story of a whole is like
hilarious dude this is great yeah it's
like okay it's like he found that even
line I'm being vulnerable and
making it coming yeah like in order to
write something like that you got to
know what the experience is like yes so
he definitely understands those weird
[ __ ] jealous emotions so yeah that
was great thanks for showing me that
should I know oh yeah it's like a
project director of coma energy I would
love for him to come out so doing you
see this video a little dickie I want
you to come perform at color by energy
that would be awesome and also bring
Lily things with you because I love that
girl she's amazing and that's she's my
chick anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the real rejects if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects uh-huh and you can check out
Selina Meyers Channel it's fun stuff
there and you can follow us but not be
funny that way
cuz I knew as soon as I said that I was
like mmm you can make a joke of it but
like I mean like sorry whatever
real nice use of age is like
philosophical and I talk a lot about
other things that aren't going sexual
like a Ryan right you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter but actually
I've been doing a lot of vines lately
because those are fun so follow us on
vine too because if we get enough
followers we can get product placement
for things such as no or receipt
companies receipts are great you know
you might purchase something and then
you have to return it example a you know
I went to the grocery store bought some
potatoes didn't like them return them
example bean went to the shop bought a
strap-on came home realized I didn't
need a strap-on cuz I already have a
penis what did you do negs then I said
Veronica do you want the strap-on to use
on me and she said no I don't want to
use the strap-on you what if you poop
and I'm like what are the chances I'll
actually poop and she's like they're
pretty high if you've never done it
before so we had to return it because of
the receipt he was able to do that
product placement accomplish